this episode of gamespot's holiday gift
guide is presented by sony entertainment
network big savings on big entertainment
each week hello and welcome to
GameSpot's holiday gift guide i'm jeff
cannata let's be honest some of us love
video games because they're an escape
there an easy way to relax or have fun
and get away from the stresses and
pressures of life but there are others
who approach gaming in a much different
way people who relish the struggle
thrive on the adversity and stare
directly into the face of the most
difficult achievements gaming has to
offer and say it on 1,001 spikes is a
throwback to the 8-bit era of
punishingly difficult platformers trying
to run your little Indiana Jones want to
be around and stay alive isn't easy and
it isn't for the faint of heart if
you're looking for endless replayability
consistent challenge and a massive
community of co adventurers then perhaps
spelunky should be your gift of choice
the extraordinarily high skill curve and
massive amounts of Secrets to uncover
means the game will never stop providing
new feats to attempt no list of
challenging games would be complete
without mentioning the trials fusion for
PC PlayStation and Xbox platforms this
is a game about repetition and pursuit
of perfection and it can be as
agonizingly difficult as it is addictive
From Software's Dark Souls 2 on pc ps3
and xbox 360 brings you into a fully
realized 3d fantasy world where every
single enemy is dangerous and only the
most patient persistent and skillful
players will survive my favorite game on
this list is rogue legacy this
old-school 16-bit side scroller retains
all the challenge you find in finely
tuned platforms like ghosts and goblins
I love this game and I couldn't
recommend it higher to anyone seeking a
tough but fair level of challenge
challenge seekers can also be the most
challenging gamers to satisfy if you're
up for it you can't go wrong by throwing
the gauntlet down with any of these
games this
holiday season thanks for watching and
good luck
you